[Music]
justin is with us justin is in lubbock
texas uh hi justin welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
oh nothing much so i'm fairly new to
dave ramsey everything like that um i
just had a quick question i'm starting a
new job where i'm going to be traveling
a lot
they're going to expense it afterwards i
know you don't like credit cards but is
it worth getting a travel credit card
for this instance when they're gonna
expense it out
well um
no but let me walk you through why okay
uh rather than just give you an answer
the um
number one i would ask that if they're
asking you to travel
on their money ask them to just give you
one of their cards
okay i mean i don't understand why this
big company needs you as their bank
need you to front them money
uh i do understand it's because
corporate america has gotten rid of
or gotten away with letting travel ride
on their employees backs for 30 days for
25 years and nobody ever called them on
it and i'm calling them on it it's
bullcrap i don't send my people out that
work here and ask them to pay for the
travel where ramsey solutions makes
money
uh well you're getting reimbursed well
why do i need why do i need uh you know
one of my guys that works here to be my
bank i've got the money
i need to just pay for his travel or her
travel right and so i first thing i do
is ask for it i'm just calling you out
corporate america you suck okay you're
riding on the back of your employees own
credit so here's the problem for you
justin two problems here's the pitfalls
and you can get away with it if you want
to get away with it but um
the pitfalls are number one i had a guy
had an mx card that was uh charged to
uh
that his company was reimbursing and
they asked him while he was in europe to
pick up twelve thousand dollars worth of
equipment and so he did
uh put in his suitcase brought it home
and when he got home and went to the
office there's padlock on the door they
filed chapter 11. he ended up with 11
000 on his amex card they did not
reimburse him
uh and uh so that that that happens
sometimes uh and then the other thing
well it'll never happen with this
company yeah right it's famous last
words but the other thing that happens
more often than that
is you've got this stupid thing in your
pocket
and um
i've traveled for 30 years
and um there's something about travel
that makes the human brain be stupid
you eat the wrong foods
you stay up too late
you
don't exercise
you
buy crap because you're bored
and that crap you can't put on your
expense report
and you end up with an extra 25 of
whatever
of what you thought you were spending at
the you spent a thousand bucks on the
company and 250 on you
that you can't get reimbursed you end up
with credit card debt is what you end up
with and i'm telling you because i've
traveled for a living and you know i
have to when i'm on the road like we're
back on the road we're back doing these
events and things i have to be
unbelievably diligent
with my
my health my food intake my spending my
eyes
everything
where my eyes go i have to be very
militant
about that because over the years i've
learned i just get fat sloppy and broke
when i travel
and it's just bad you know and because
hey justin let me give you let me give
you a third one i'll give you a third
one uh i did this once
when i was in college and i was uh
a student leader and so i would put all
the school purchases on my personal
credit card and the school just
reimbursed me
and i thought i was running a scam here
because i was trying to build up miles
and all that kind of nonsense that's a
whole other call but here's what
happened
in the middle of the gap one month i um
my transmission fell out of or my clutch
ramp burned out all my on my little
cheap toyota that i was driving
at the same moment i got a thousand
dollar reimbursement check
i did not have a thousand dollars or 700
bucks whatever cost to get a new clutch
and so i had that check i cashed it and
i went and got my car fixed and that
money did not go right back into the pot
to pay the credit card off yeah and so
the life hit me in the gap there and it
i just didn't have the discipline to do
it very very few people do that's why we
don't play with them and so what i do is
i set up what i suggest you do is you
set up a separate account checking
account for just travel only
reimbursable expenses
uh how much you think your travel is
going to be in a month
i wouldn't expect it to get more than
four or five thousand dollars
okay as quickly as you can seed that one
account with three or four thousand
bucks
okay
and use a debit card
and then basically you're using your
money and then you're putting the money
back into your account that you've used
of your money from them that will cause
your brain to
uh function differently when you see
something in the airport gift store that
you think you need that you don't need
and because there's nothing in an
airport gift store that anyone actually
needs hey and just so
people understand what dave was saying
earlier um i go on the road all the time
doing private things doing things with
the team
before i leave an envelope literally
appears on my desk with travel cash in
it that is a
it's you putting money in my pocket for
travel yeah we if you're not someone
that carries a company debit card we
french at the cash put cash literally
cash that's right and you mentioned an
entre in entre leadership book once and
i thought i'd never thought of this
before
people challenge you on giving your
employees company debit cards like how
could you trust them to do that
and your response in the book
it's been a fear since i read it but it
was something to the effect of if you
don't trust somebody enough
don't hire them right if you can't give
them two thousand dollars they shouldn't
be around your brand on there and they
pay them 150 grand
what kind of idiot are you you know i
mean you can't trust them with i mean
you hired somebody you can't trust with
two grand but you pay them 150 and they
represent your brand yeah that's oh my
god it's dumber than a rock yeah but
corporate america is dumber than a rock
so i'll just tell you they're just
stupid bag of hair